on this Good Friday I want to tell you a
story of transformation and Redemption
if you look back at the last few years
model Blac Chyna was starring in
tabloids on only fans and stuck in some
major public feuds but now she's
deactivated her only fans account she
got baptized and she's even started
going by her birth name Angela Renee
White this week she announced her latest
achievement getting her doctorate from a
Bible College joining me now is Angela
White Angela thank you so much for being
here happy Easter or Holy Week anyway
what was the deciding factor for you to
make this change I mean you were making
great money you achieved Fame why did
you give that life up
I had to honestly the life that I was
living it was fast-paced you know money
coming in money going out you know and I
just honestly kept running into like all
these problems and these issues and this
and that and lawsuits
and I was like you know what like I need
a change like I have to change my life I
can't be living like this I have two
beautiful babies I have businesses and I
had to really just get back to myself I
kind of lost myself honestly hmm what
was there one moment that you said I've
gotta I've got to change this now was it
one deciding moment
it was I mean the decided moment was on
my birthday so I got baptized on my
birthday and then from there I just
started putting in the work you know
people um have to also realize once you
get baptized you have to be willing to
also change everything about you so you
can start moving into the light yeah and
Angela you talked about removing one of
your tattoos on Instagram I want to talk
to you about this listen okay
y'all know that I had this Baphomet
tattoos right
it got to come off you know what I mean
I'm not about to have no mark of the
beast anything like that I just don't
want anything negative or demonic on my
body anymore
Angela when did you realize how
dangerous this was spiritually and this
wasn't uh the only addition that you
removed from your body by the way
the more I started reading the Bible you
know and it's it's so bizarre to me
because at the time I didn't see nothing
wrong with it and that's like the issue
you know we don't see things that we're
doing wrong because we're actually
sitting in that moment and I just
started like praying to the praying to
God you know and taking the proper steps
going to church and just really just
really just focus in like on myself and
my spirit yeah well I love that it's not
only a spiritual transformation but a
physical one I mean you've had fillers
in your face dissolved you're removing
tattoos what's next for Angela White
what's next for me I'm going to continue
my journey with the Bible for sure and
just work on myself just honestly work
on myself and work on my businesses and
different ways of making income because
the way that I was making income wasn't
right so now I have to like really just
D dive dive deep into my studies and to
my work ethic well the new Angela
featured perfectly thank you and have a
blessed Easter thanks for being with you
too thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else